faudrait la notice pour savoir dans
quelles sont malaisés cool tu as fait
comme ça au menu pâtes à pizza toulon
orange ambulants faire mais toi t'en a
pas marre casser l'ambiance mais je
compte jusqu'à trois mois celui qui me
cacher il a gagné 1 2 3 j'ai gagné mais
ce thème il s'agit aujourd'hui d'une
vidéo un peu au made connaissez lorraine
lucioles en fait on s'est dit ça peut
être drôle de faire une activité
manuelle bricolage sauf qu'en vrai je
vais pas acheter un meuble et le monter
pour ensuite le jeter c'est inutile mais
souvenez-vous on vient d'arriver dans un
nouveau bureau donc là on a plein de
meubles on a un espace très vide avec
une réverbération très chiant donc on va
faire les deux ans d'un vous allez
suivre dans cette vidéo je pense qu'on
l'a tourné sur plusieurs jours vous
allez suivre le montage de tous nos
nouveaux bureaux des meubles de la déco
de tout l'aménagement de l'espace
balade dans cette vidéo quoi ah oui la
dernière fois que j'ai essayé d'être
bricoleur c'était avec cyprien en vidéo
avec la perceuse bosch d'ailleurs pour
ceux qui ceux qui soutiennent cette
vidéo vous êtes les anciens c'est
officiel et d'ailleurs est ce que c'est
pas le retour de la personne n'y a pas
qu'à droite on est juste nous aussi nos
nouveaux bureaux et on prend tout à la
main et voilà une vidéo un peu cool
pourquoi une déception de voir les
visuels va être incroyable qu'on sait
pas
[Musique]
j'aimerais bien commencer par le canapé
c'est un vrai symbole je trouve dans un
endroit quand tu poses de canapés genre
t'es trop à l'aise ouais j'suis d'accord
sachant que on a aussi des meubles pour
la terrasse que du coup on va devoir
faire plus tard dans la vidéo parce que
là il ya un nid de guêpes
voilà un petit nid de guêpes
on commence par le canap way aller oui
oui mais il faudrait la notice pour
savoir dans quel sens mais les écrous la
non mais il n'y a pas besoin de notices
il ya le petit écrou la petite zone
plate la petite zone plate avec dénivelé
je crois que la zone plate dénivelé ont
déjà eu je crois tu vois ça s'arrête là
alors on cherche la notice
mais vous n'avez pas confiance en moi
c'est vraiment une bonne idée de vidéos
bah tu étais convaincu toujours je pense
que les gens ils vont être mort de rire
mais sur fou rire de leur vie quoi ils
vont être l'adjointe à peu pour l'agen à
la haine à la 2 e à la 3 papa match et
ils ont dit que ça a duré 30 minutes on
a mis beaucoup moins on a vraiment mis
45 au lavis nommé ailleurs un craquement
non non non non il faut être méthodique
tu peux pas laisser ça comme ça une
rampe de skate haut niveau a ressenti
sur ce premier meuble epub ouf
est ce que tu as déjà vu un mec faire ça
[Musique]
tu aurais préféré vous allez voir annexe
à la notice alors c'est cinq minutes
s'est agi des roulettes annette qui
tient dans le carton comme un cercueil
vient on prend quelqu'un well est ce que
tu peux venir de nous aider pour un truc
on a besoin d'être plusieurs vas-y elle
n'avait rien de l'ordre à l'écurie
galère un peu et après ici on a ce
carton là où là il faudrait de quoi mais
toi t'en a pas marre de casser
l'ambiance toro on n'a pas besoin de
touraine en fait un ton car messieurs
dames
le mahb roulettes est prêt à gérer les
tours de magie la femme coupée en deux
ce que je te propose beaucoup de gens
qui montent des meubles en particulier
mois en défaut spécifique c'est celui de
ne pas évacuer les choses aux femmes il
faut qu'on évacue au fur et à mesure
sinon on va jamais s'y retrouver jamais
jamais jamais je sais ce point fr
[Musique]
on va leur faire un super le buffet le
buffet avait moi j'en connais une qui ne
l'est pas commander ce méfait et ben je
vais mener s embrasser la fenêtre est
ouverte c'est là on entend des trucs ça
s'enfonce dans le bon bout d'un moment
attaché comme ça tu vas fait dans le
mauvais sens mais ce que ça change
quelque chose
en vrai nom mode ça t'arrange c'est ce
lien
voilà un vrai de vrai ça tient ensemble
j'espère juste sera pas bancal tu as une
honte est donc la ségo sa tuque c'est
pas le moment de mettre basile de six
ans plus tard messieurs dames lamento du
studio monsieur basel
[Musique]
c'est la mascotte voilà tout ce qui va
au mur moi ici sur ce mur y aura des
étagères murales comme ça dans un hammam
et laval y aura un portemanteau donc le
but c'est de les accrocher et ce à tout
ce qui est murale c'est ma hantise genre
c'est horrible l'idée c'est de les
mettre les unes après les autres
ici en dessous des autres tu veux dire
évidemment
on va mettre des chevilles qui font six
millimètres de diamètre donc c'est celle
ci qu'il faut je suis en panique bon
vas-y on teste
vas-y aussi un fils un fils je me fais
électrocuté au [ __ ] je sais pas je
pense pas j'aime pas du tout ah oui
pas
eh ben c'est parti pour les autres
musique rock'n'roll
[Musique]
mais sion accompli le porte-manteau
aulas cherche je suis genre le boss du
bricolage pas du tout je mets juste une
glisse dans une cheminée comment ça ne
m'énerve ça alors on n'a pas le niveau
c'est hyper dur comment tu veux faire
bah bien voir la cam ça se voit pas du
tout qu'il ait pas droit ça se voit
je me mets bien droit de face excuse moi
mais ça va non non moi je fais ça passe
là c'est le dernier challenge on va
mettre ça au dessus du but fait ça ne
pèse que 45 fois le poids de ses
étagères l'idée c'est d'être droit et de
1 mois d'offre au cas où ma gueule ok
les amis c'est le moment où on pose le
miroir et on croise les doigts
à tout moment j'ai mal mesuré moi tout
se passe bien vite ou alors elle attend
est après trouves tu tiens je bouge pas
at home pourquoi il pose toi sinon on
pose dessus rien il est posé sur la
wiesmann attend real j'ai montré en fait
regarder le truc là derrière
il est posé dessus au lieu que la vie
soit dedans mais bon pas vu pas pris
les gars on a mis ça tout seul est
franchement déjà justesse le peu qu'on a
fait là je suis vraiment content genre
ce qui nous manque en fait les amis je
vais vous montrer encore là ici il y
aura des tableaux au dessus du canapé
là il y aurait une telle est évidemment
là bas y aura mon bureau mais on n'a pas
encore reçu mon bureau mais pourquoi je
crie alors j'ai un chef c'est un support
est ici à une bibliothèque qui rend
l'âme est pareil il faut qu'on la
commande mais en tout cas on a nos
étagères murales le miroir basile qu'il
est important
ouais la terrasse quand y aura plus de
guêpe la terrasse quand il y aura plus
de get en vrai une au restaurant je
consens
une deux journées on peut faire le reste
on peut se dire eiffage pour aujourd'hui
je suis épuisé
allez c'est parti on commence par la
table de réunion table de réunion c'est
hyper important
nous on a besoin des fois de se poser de
brainstorm et d'avoir quelques idées de
toutes les occasions
et vous savez que les b elles sont ou
furent cette chaîne et elle demande
beaucoup de temps à être mise en place
aujourd'hui deux autres histoires
trouver sur les notes mais trois
histoires trois nouvelles histoires
trois histoires trois nouvelles
histoires aujourd'hui nous vous sauverez
d'itasy veille et s'est parfaitement
elles élevées à la hâte en attente déjà
est ce qu'on la pose au sol on va
écraser un chiffre elle est belle elle
est massive
la massivité l'objet au la vache ouais
ok et à trouver mal surtout en vrai
c'est assez simple à faire tu veux pas
faire les chaises sont donc frais la
table et on s'envoie des mails et sms
pour se tenir au courant garazi ça
marche
[Musique]
orange est une grande nouvelle ouais
j'ai presque fini un pied à moi j'ai
presque fini une chaise à 20 minutes
[Musique]
merci j'ai blessé basile aux plaines tu
tapes sur le cul
bonjour bienvenue à la réunion un seul
bris dit oui elle est belle rempli la
table de réunion est en place l'étagère
est en place et maintenant c'est l'heure
de passer au bureau donc y en a un qui
va ici dans l'angle est un qui va là bas
tu vois c'est le bureau d'angle qui va
être la lorraine on a après moi je dois
rentrer faire le lac du jeudi
il est 18 heures on a deux heures
franchement le fais je vais pas que les
cartons et on s'y met nazi né dans la
merde de fous je vous dis un truc c'est
que c'est le bureau jarvis le même que
j'ai chez moi depuis très longtemps
gotaga m'avait conseillé cd magnifique
d'euros
franchement quand ils sont montés y tue
mais quand tu dois le monter il ya des
rails
il ya plein de câbles et une alim il ya
des pieds c'est chacun sa merde
chacun son chemin je vais monter le mien
mais là moi j'étais quelqu'un pour
monter le principe de la vie des océans
agricole elle vient de dire j'ai fait
appeler quelqu'un pour le monter il faut
un bac plus il faut un master ingénieur
ouais il faut il faut des compétences je
suis désolé concours est un bijou
aubazine qu'on a à moitié en asie
messieurs dames j'ai fini mon bureau en
premier regardez il est là il est beau
natsu fait sa sieste et aucun doute du
monsieur
le butin moi je peux pas t'aider lévis
lcd spaling peur je t'ai entendu dire
une phrase juste avant tu as dit la
phrase suivante je vais mettre davis au
pif
est ce que tu es pas en train de vivre
la conséquence d'un ami davis fifa
l'asie on va tourner mon bureau ouais
comme ça appréhendez-vous je peux
rentrer vers le lac du jeune soir vas-y
la exact je vais dégager les cartons et
demain c'est le dernier jour de
l'aménagement voici en a mis trois jours
à demain lorraine ce qu'il faisait il ya
un truc à l'est pas as-tu voulu de quel
côté de l'en but tu connais mon camion
[Musique]
bourré de mort je te laisse te démonter
remonter au niveau des mains bises ou le
renne affiné d'assemblée son bureau
monsieur cogner et voilà les trop beau
et villas et les beaux et du coup la
foule branché ouais et après il va se
lever hu
incroyable donc on fait une petite
simulation oui rentrée bienvenue mais
n'était pas censé venir verlan
bienvenue tellement pratique écoutez moi
bien j'étais en train de ranger cette
table et je constate un truc assez ouf
il reste tout suivi qu'est ce que je
fais je m'accroupir pour voir ce qu'il
ya sous le bureau de lorraine et je
m'aperçois c'est quoi ça là vous voyez
pas ionia un coup il n'y a pas de
l'islam ait pas de vices plus loin là
toujours pas de vis l'appareil il ya un
trou là dans le truc en métal et ici il
ya un trou prévu à cette fin on le voit
on les a clairement et toi ils sont t'as
dit quoi c'est pas ta j'en ai marre les
amis on a touché une amie de mauvaise
foi mais elle c'est un truc de ouf genre
ça va moins ça va moins bien tenir que
si tu avais juste ok c'est peut-être un
petit peu moins solide que ça devrait
l'être mais ça marche quand même très
bien et me dis pas tu as fait à toulon
non je vois des trucs flagrant ya
l'emplacement pour mettre la ville
lorraine ldk de la barre est allé
menzies dans le bois en bref bref bref
c'est chiant gens comprennent rien en
plus s'en foutent complètement est ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est que lauren
homme très malade et son bureau bon là
décor on passe à la déco tu peux me
filme en train de faire le ménage ça
avec tellement de talent qu'il faut te
filmer c'est ça
[Musique]
fin du bain narnia trop de trucs on a
ramené dans un studio qui me font
plaisir cette fille bas demandent par
exemple ce petit bob qui tombe un peu
vers l'avant malheureusement ça on s'en
souvient aussi dans une vieille vidéo
avec ma fille carys tôt mais attend il
manque qui manquent
il manquait un truc de fou voilà ce
qu'on veut aux mais aussi il faut le
faut les remettre fois il a pris cher
jakiloup pauvres je vous aime
faites pas attention il ya une
décoloration en cours lorraine vient de
vivre l'enfer lorraine et on a une une
échappatoire de natsuki a tenté de
partir vers d'autres horizons en sortant
par la porte de l'entrée corps et il
fait si jamais le chien traverser le
trottoir d'en face
bah il aurait traversé je pense à 70km
l'art combien de voitures passent sur
cette avenue tous les jours non par jour
aux avait des milliers cinquantaine de
millions oui mais sereine la prochaine
fois que tu sors de ce studio et se
ferment la porte j'ai besoin qu'on est à
huit jours de travaux d'avoir fini alors
qu'en fait non il faut juste qu'on range
tout bien et vous allez voir ça aurait
de la gueule
ici je dois mettre l'ancien cav dernière
d'abonnés ici on de monter sur mon
bureau mal vie ces batailles camus elvis
et j'ai un pressentiment de foirade qui
est énorme
non moi je le sens bien je dois l'avouer
bien plus fait chier celui-là me
soutient a dormi mais bon à la seppic c
mais quand même ces [ __ ] de l'automne
ok huawei mais c'est pas de moi balaj
mort mais là c'était pas pas droit à la
catastrophe à l'âge vous coûte que c'est
par le fonds ça fait un petit côté alice
au pays des merveilles sachiez messieurs
dames la journée touche à sa fin on a à
peu près fini tout ce qu'on voulait
faire après le reste ce sera de
l'ajustement petit à petit mais le gros
est fait y'a plus qu'à recevoir les
ordis et les écrans et on est parés à
bosser ici on a passé un mois à faire ça
je suis mort je trouve donc on a aménagé
nous mêmes cette pièce en vrai je pense
que c'était la meilleure chose à faire
ce qu'il ya vraiment un sentiment
d'accomplissement ah ouais ça fait
plaisir
et je n'en reviens pas qu'on ait mis ce
miroir nous-mêmes je n'en reviens pas
façon il va tomber d'ici 10 jours mais
en tout cas d'ici là c'était
spectaculaire
j'ai une confession à faire attention ça
va faire mal je veux pas faire de décor
là bas dans mon cas j'ai beaucoup je
vais tourner les vidéos pourquoi parce
que je veux continuer tourné sur fond
vert
ça offre des possibilités au montage qui
sont trop marrante et aussi je peux
tourner un peu d'où je veux tant que
j'ai un fond vert
mais ce qui est très positif c'est que
je veux quand même un décor
actuellement je tourne déjà sur fond
vert et on met une photo de mon ancien
décor à la place du pont vers là
j'aimerais qu'on mette un nouveau décor
fait en 3d pourquoi je dis ça parce que
j'ai découvert un artiste qui a modélisé
complètement mon ancien studio et il l'a
fait c'est incroyablement bien le
résultat
et du coup je me suis dit c'est un
donner une idée je me suis dit mais j'ai
envie de faire participer les gens qui
fera le bes décor pour les vidéos et que
l'on on en sélectionne un conte utilise
ensuite pour les vidéos et puis en avoir
plusieurs aient pu en avoir un pour les
serait d'horreur 1 pour les sabres et
10,1 pour jose rien pour chaque type de
vidéo mais en tout cas je veux vraiment
ce truc de continuer à tourner sur fond
vert
on va créer une adresse mail qui
s'appelle squeeze le décor 3d @ gmail
point com à laquelle vous pouvez envoyer
le décor que vous aurez créé donc ça
doit juste être une image donc de face
un tout petit peu en plongée est donc
chassé une image fixe soit c'est une
longue vidéo de cinq secondes si vous
voulez animé deux trois trucs très léger
dans le décor et moi ce que je fais
c'est que je ferai un live où je regarde
tout ce que vous m'avez envoyé aux
ensembles on sélectionnera plusieurs
décors qu'on utilisera ensuite dans les
vidéos sur la chaîne principale est ce
qu'on utilisera on rémunérera l'auteur
voilà donc tous toute cette vidéo
bricolage pour finalement vous dire que
vous ne devez plus du tout les meubles
d'être aviez vu
bravo à toi l'om on a bien rigolé c'est
incroyable j'ai beaucoup rigolé c'était
vraiment je dis pas je leur ferai mais
là on est bien et vous avez vécu ça avec
nous au début de la vidéo la pièce est
évident ouais c'est ça qui est dingue en
fait au début c'est que les cartons moi
je me suis déjà vachement habitué à la
voir je vais rentrer dormir je suis
épuisée je vous souhaite à tous une
excellente soirée merci avoir regardé
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
malgré tout ce qui n'allait pas non
c'est amusant
[Musique]
mais montage était pas
j'ai tout
sur terre
mais là
même en
basile